Less than 60% of Africans get over that pregnancy
here at the European Commission.
So for those who do,
what are they see we look like?
Let's ask them.
I'm a Blue Book trainee at the cabinet of the High
Representative and Vice President of the commission.
I am doing a Blue Book trainee ship
at the Legal Service of the European Commission.
I'm a Blue Book trainee at the MSCA unit of DJSC.
I have a background in international relation
and before my Blue Book trainee ship,
I worked as a research assistant in a think tank
based in Spain
and I also volunteered in AKIPA Europa
which is a European youth association.
I studied at NELLALAM
at the college of Europe
and at dual BAA at the university of Manila,
Madrid in law and Political Science.
I also funded an organization,
AKIPA Europa
to promote the European Union amongst the youth.
And I was part of the high level advisory group
on the conference on the future of Europe.
I was a Mercury Fellow myself
and I have a PhD in nano medicine based cancer research
and I'm the current chair of the Communications
Working Group for Mercury Alumni Associations.
I can speak Spanish,
English, French,
Italian, uh, fluently
and a bit of Arabic.
I speak English,
French and Spanish.
Hindi, Spanish,
German and a bit of French.